Okay, so it is my great
pleasure to introduce Chen Li,
whom I've known,
of course, for many years.
He did his PhD at Stanford and
is now a full professor at
UC Irvine,
University of California Irvine.
And his area, like mine,
has been around data management
system, mostly query processing,
text analytics.
And query processing means both
execution and optimization.
He got the NSF CAREER award,
he was also our program
coach here for PLTB 2000?
>> 15.
>> 15, yes.
And he also did a startup,
so he's a full package.
So without much further
introduction, Chen,
take it away.
And he's gonna talk about how
the Office research products.
>> All right, Sergei,
thanks for hosting my visit.
It has been a while for me.
Last time I visited here was
more than maybe five years ago,
and it's good to see
all the old friends,
also to see some new faces.
So the last few years, as a
surrogate, I took some adventure
to try to do a startup, to
commercialize some of my work.
It's a pretty
eye-opening experience,
pretty interesting and
crucial for people who have done
a startup before, like Adon,
you know how it feels.
And I came back about two or
three years ago,
and that experience
taught me many things.
The one thing I learned was
being in academia or in general
in this research field, building
systems is more exciting.
Even before I did a startup,
together with my colleague Mike
Kerry, we were building an open
source project called Acid DB,
which I'll talk about briefly.
And after I came back,
I continued developing that
project and also building
some other systems.
So in this talk, I want to use
the time to give you an overview
of what I've been doing for
the last few years.
And I want to make at
a little bit high-level.
Maybe one, two places,
I will become technical, but
you're very welcome to talk
about some technical details.
In addition,
I talk about two systems, and
both systems have demos.
And roughly,
I want to spend about two-thirds
of my time on the first system,
and then one-third of the time
on the second system.
But we can obviously
talk offline about
some of the issues.
So the first project
is called Cloudberry.
And the motivation is
about how to support big
queries in sub-seconds, okay?
And I know I talked to some
of the colleagues here,
I know there are a lot
of work in this space.
And I'm telling you what do
we wanna do in this space.
So at a high level,
Cloudberry is a general
purpose middleware solution,
which can support interactive
analytics and visualization.
And it supports different
kinds of backends,
different databases.
Of course we have the BIOS of
supporting an Acid DB, but
it also support other databases.
And we also support different
kinds of front ends.
So even though the first demo
is a kind of visualization,
I want to emphasize this part
is not about visualization,
it's about supporting
visualization.
For example, Tableau can be
one of our front end users.
Okay, so I'm going to start
the first part with a demo.
So the demo I'm gonna show here
is, both demos about the social
media analysis, even though both
solutions are general purpose.
So for this demo,
we call it Twitter map,
it's one application of
Cloudberry club area.
I want to differentiate between
Cloudberry and Twitter map,
because Cloudberry can support
different kinds of applications.
For this Twitter map demo,
the backend has about
this number of tweets,
close to 1 billion tweets,
collected over 1 year and
10 months,
starting from November 2015.
It is about, roughly,
1% of all the US tweets, okay.
Still, it's a small number,
I know many people have seen
bigger scales, but
it's a proof of concept.
And plus the backend is
using parallel solutions, so
if you have more data,
we just need more hardware,
the whole thing is scalable.
So the goal we want to achieve
in this project is for this
amount of data, with textual,
temporal and spatial conditions,
we wanna allow the user to
be able to see the data from
different angles, by submitting
different kinds of conditions.
Okay, so my example, currently,
we have this
Hurricane Irma coming.
And here, we are lucky because
we're in the Northwest,
[LAUGH] very far from Florida.
But let's say we want to see
how the social media is talking
about hurricanes.
Okay, so we can just type
in the keyword hurricane,
even though you can
type in any keyword.
So the user types in
this keyword, and
we want to see all the tweets,
that is an aggregation results.
The number of tweets mentioning
hurricane per state.
And we show the map with
the aggregation results.
We also show the histogram
over different time periods.
So you can see some
of sample tweets.
Here, currently
it is like a 141.
And this one, 139, is real
I didn't censor the tweets,
okay, so don't be offended
by the words there.
It's very organic.
So we get some rough idea
about the distribution.
And people may say, what if you
look at the population of one
state, and do the division or
do the normalization?
We can allow to
do normalization,
to see on the average how
many tweets per person,
are talking the hurricane
in each state.
You can still get the idea.
Still, you can see Texas and
Florida, these are two states
that people are very
concerned about this topic.
>> Virginia appears to be
be very concerned also.
>> [LAUGH]
>> For whatever reason.
>> Maybe [INAUDIBLE] everything.
>> It's interesting, you see
that there are two peaks.
The second peak is
not surprising.
There's a peak here, maybe for
some reason last summer there
was some, maybe hurricane,
that was very troublesome.
So you can pick a range for
the time dimension, and
then the results will be updated
with those answers within that
time range.
>> And you can easily
change your time window,
by changing the start time or
ending time, or
you can even slide the window.
So as the user changes
the conditions on the time
dimension, and the system can
responsively give the results
for this amount of data, okay?
And then let's say,
what if the user wants to
go deeper into that data?
So let's say, in Texas, we wanna
see within Texas, how the tweets
are geographically located,
based on different counties.
So we zoom in, we show all
the different regions,
different counties, and
then the color will indicate
the density per county.
Okay, and you can go even
further down to even the county
level and
pick just one of them, Houston.
And then at this level,
now we show the city-level
aggregate results.
So now for us, we show
three different levels, but
you can define your
own hurricane, and
we allow it to zoom in, zoom
out, in this space dimension,
and text, and the time,
given dimensions.
And the main thing is, for
these about 1 billion records,
which is about 1
terabyte of data,
how we can do these kinds of
queries within subseconds.
So this is what we
want to achieve.
And on the backend, this is kind
of a mini cluster we're using.
Now, we moved it
to into my office.
The backend is running
a cluster of six nook.
Boxes.
Each one is about $800
with half terabyte of SSD,
16 gigabytes of memory, and
I think maybe two cords,
or four cords, I forgot.
And we use heavily would
rely on the disk or
the flash drive to
make it scalable.
Since the whole
infrastructure is parallel,
if you have more data just
throw in more boxes, but
total budget's about
less than $5,000 okay?
So within $5000 we wanna deliver
these kind of user experiences.
So now let's see what's
happening behind the scenes.
So this is what CloudBerry
is capable of doing.
Architectural wise,
CloudBerry is a middleware
that sits on top of
your existing database.
And, the one we saw just now,
the back end is using AsterixDB.
Because we have a connector that
talks to the database using
our native language.
Two languages, we're bilingual.
EQL and SQLS*Plus.
And we also recently just
built one more connector or
two more connectors.
One talking to MySQL,
one talking to a [INAUDIBLE].
Plus the requirement is your
database should provide or
your backend, not database,
your backend should provide core
language either through database
[INAUDIBLE] or RESTful API so
that the middleware can talk to
you by issuing some queries.
In this you will miss
some assumptions.
One assumption is the data for
now is append only,
once your data, because somehow
logic relies on assumption,
once the data is already
inserted into your tables,
we can not modify anymore.
And we know a lot of cases
such as this condition,
we have one more assumption
we show you later.
And the CloudBerry mediaware
that's a lot of techniques
optimization is to
deliver that kind of
view experiences which
I'll explain later.
>> You allow joint queries.
>> We allow joint queries,
we support all kinds of queries.
Some of [INAUDIBLE]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay, I'll talk about the
front end library, the front-end
API here, we use a RESTful API.
But the RESTful API is kind of
a SQL, using a JSON format.
Okay, I use this one here.
So for Asterix DB, I think
I'll just talk about briefly,
Mike and
I have been building, and
some other colleagues from
Riverside, other Couchbase.
We've been building this one for
last seven years.
At the high level,
it combines the techniques from
semistructure data management,
parallel database systems,
and Hadoop and its friends into
one system, it's open source in
Java, essentially it's a power
databases with all the support.
Storage, indexing, clear
processing, clear optimization,
clear language,
the whole stack, okay?
There's a shared
[INAUDIBLE] architecture,
we dont take the other approach
it's like an Oracle is taking
some of their products, we just
assume people kept throwing in
some commodities hardware
easily to make it scalable.
These are some of
features AsterixDB has.
Semi-structured data models,
will support ptree,
rtree invert index all of them,
that covers a lot of data types.
We use RCM For dynamic data.
Similar to other
systems like Mongo and.
And, we have our own runtime
engine called Hyrex.
We have our own query language.
Now, previously it's called AQL.
Coming from a x query.
Now, people that don't like
x query People like SQL, so
we change it to SQL Plus Plus.
The plus plus part supports
same structured part, okay?
And we are being working with
Couchbase very closely and
the recent announcement from
them says, Couchbase decided to
use the backend AsterixDB
to support their analytics.
That's a one-minute
overview of AsterixDB.
So let me focus on Cloudberry.
So let me first talk
about this API here and
how the middleware
talks to the front end.
I use a very simple example.
In an earlier demo we
used hurricane, but
here uses Zika which
is very similar.
So, from the fountain
application perspective,
it would talk to Cloudberry
through a RESTful API because we
know web service architecture
is more and more integratable.
Right, you can plug
into anyplace.
And, plus by doing this RESTful
API it can kind of provide
uniform interface for
the front and the top for
this layer which can
talk to given databases.
Potentially this layer could
do even in the greater from
databases but
for now each instance only
talks to a single database.
So this is the query.
You turn it into signals
more like, I want to get
the number of trees per stage
that mention the key word Zika.
Okay?
And this is the SQL in
a JSON format, okay.
But they use different language.
And we have many
different way to find
certain properties like
what you're talking to.
And what kind of a predicate
you want to ask or
post to that table.
We have to group by
on which attribute or
attributes you want
to do the group by.
And when you do a group by,
what kind of application
you want to do?
Count, sum, Mean, max,
they all configurable.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> User defined aggregates,
so far no.
So we just do user
standard aggregates.
But I wanna mention few things,
the middleware
is doing it to achieve
that performance.
I mentioned some of them in
the meetings this morning.
One thing is caching,
not surprisingly.
In example,
if a user types in hurricane,
the first time the user
types in hurricane,
then the engine would do
the work, the mediaware would
translate that query into
a simple query to backend, or
even moderate query
depending on the semantics.
And then the results of
the hurricane query would be
restored as a view and
materialize inside a database,
as one of the tables.
And from database perspective,
they don't know what it is,
just one of the tables.
So it's up to the media ware to
decide the meaning of this view
and how to maintain it.
This is the larger we do here.
And later we'll cover the case
where what if we don't
have a view available there?
And there's a second technique
that we're doing there.
Now at the high level
this one looks a little
bit very overwhelming.
The main idea is if the user
has typed in a drug, a Zika or
hurricane and then the
middleware has decided to put
the results into a view,
into a database,
there's still a lot of issues
we had to solve, which is, how
can we make the view consistent
with the backend database.
Because, our principle is, we
want to support real time query
processing, meaning When the
user types in a query we want
to give the user latest results.
That just came in maybe
five minutes ago.
To do it our current
solution is the developer,
the system admin has to decide
a frequency in which the middlle
ware or the view and the base
table should be synchronized.
So let's assume it's one hour,
so
every hour the middleware
will trigger logic to tell
the database to put the latest
tweets about hurricane,
the delta, and
put the delta into the view.
Okay this is done
by the middleware.
The still issue is even
if the view is maintain
synchronize with the base
table every hour What if, so
now, it is like 1:15, right?
Last time it was synchronized
it was at 1:00 o'clock.
There are still some records
that came in in the last 15
minutes.
So, we also want to include
this, the latest entries
that came in the last 15
minutes, in the results.
So, what the middleware is doing
is, if at this moment that we
ask for hurricane twist, it will
first talk to the view, which
is the full hurricane twist to
fetch all the twist, which is
much smaller compared to the
entire 1 billion record table.
In addition, it will also
talk to the base table,
to get all the trees that just
came in the last 15 minutes.
Then the middle
[INAUDIBLE] combination.
>> Yeah, so
I have two questions.
>> Sure.
>> So, the first one is do
[INAUDIBLE] storage agent for
the systems of the data,
the same to all the parts
are value [INAUDIBLE].
>> This is the back end,
this is the middleware.
There's view, maintain it's
logic by the middleware.
From an Adespex data
perspective, it is a table.
>> So, this way, the Azure DB
is just storing the data-
>> Yes, just store.
>> More like a storage engine?
>> Correct, correct.
>> The other thing is
that merging the results
from archive the data and
the new incoming data.
>> Right.
>> Do you assume
the data is sort of
append [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yes.
Yeah, that's why we made
assumption, we assume the data
that came in last 15 minutes
is not modifying earlier data.
>> Okay.
>> That's why we need
this assumption.
Do you have a question
[INAUDIBLE]?
>> I was just thinking that,
for example,
in many cases that the dev
from a streaming system,
it's not going to like, the time
for this to get cluster.
>> Azure DB, yeah.
>> Right there and
it's gonna be kind of too long.
If you have to pull from, let's
say, I don't know something
that's coming from an event you
have Microsoft staff, or for
example, any of this.
So, an eventing system, then
how quickly, that's one, and
the main question there is
related to that if your query
is a dynamic query, it's a not
a register standing query.
Then many other things that
you're talking about the views
are not really actionable.
So, how much flexibility
are on the fly?
So, you have a rich API, but
that's different from saying
can I write an ad [INAUDIBLE]
query just in time and
you can actually search history.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, for
the first one about
the [INAUDIBLE].
We in this architecture we treat
it at the problem for databases.
>> I see.
>> The data comes
from the back door.
As long as, data is with me,
in terms of architecture,
the cover doesn't care about
how it accomplishes it.
As long as it is visible
through a query it will get it.
Right, so it's very [INAUDIBLE]
business to make sure
if you have fast data
that comes to the system,
they are visible to the query.
The transaction probability
is should be guarantee.
But doesn't care about the.
>> Right, just thing from many
of the newly coming events
situation.
Well, how realistic
that assumption I mean.
>> Yes, is because when we
developed this software,
we assumed we treated your
database as a black box.
>> With the rich query.
>> Yeah, it's basically SQL for
now operations.
This is what we need.
And for the second issue,
if you wanna do a what
you really mean, like kind
of a continuous queries.
If a user subscribes
query to the system whether
the system can periodically,
or continuously give the user
the update of that query.
Is that what you mean?
>> [CROSSTALK] answer
that question you have
never seen this work before,
right?
>> Right.
>> So, there's a distinction
between a query
template versus
parameter of the query.
I'm talking about the query
itself, the template itself,
not the parameter of the query.
>> So far in the kernel we have
done the view materialization,
we assume each view
has a keyword for now.
So, we have a hurricane view, we
could have like an armor view,
we could have zinger view.
And then-
>> Okay, are they have to be
known a?
>> No, no, no.
>> On the fly?
>> It's not on the fly.
It's all those difference.
I think,
in some of the earlier work,
people would have to do some
kind of all flying like
collecting a histogram
amount of information.
The one person we follow is,
we start from scratch.
The views will be offline
created and maintained.
We don't do offline datacubes.
We don't do offline like
workload analysis and
see which of the views
should be virtualized.
And one more thing that's very
real for our case, at least for
this case text is very common.
And the user can type
in arbitrary keywords.
It's very hard to decide what
kind of keyword you can write.
So, it won't do everything
on the fly, okay,
there's no offline
process per step.
>> Do you always maintain the
view inside the same database
that the original data is in,
or do you also provide for
being able to do that
in the separate system.
>> Yeah, the question is
really about if we always put
the views into
the send database.
Currently, we do.
We treat you back in the
database like a storage layer,
and when I put some
results there you do it.
If possible we can always have
a separate database just to
store views.
That's doable, but
he didn't do it.
Okay, other questions?
>> So, I'm just curious
whether the keywords,
the search is exact keyword
search, or more than that?
>> So far we haven't done
any like, but advanced,
expansion, [INAUDIBLE] those
are things we have not done yet.
This is only kind
of the first step.
I [INAUDIBLE] who is working
on this [INAUDIBLE].
We know how to do it,
it's just a matter of time.
Next thing I want to say is,
back to your tutorial, right?
What if the views
are not available.
The first time user, it gives
the query, hurricane, there's
nothing inside that database,
in the views, how can we do it?
So, people in here
are expert in the topic.
So, when we first developed
the prototype one year ago,
that's the first point,
is the user experience,
which is really troublesome.
Because whenever
I show them all,
I always try to show [LAUGH]
key word, I have issues before.
But in the audience,
people can give me as
an operative key word,
this is what I
usually experienced.
Which is not nice.
So, what we decided to do,
is this approach,
which is you do,
first and last name.
I wanna go a little bit
deeper with this topic,
cuz I talked to some
people in this audience.
That the reason we
take this approach is
we want to treat the back
end data base as a box.
We do not want to make any
change in the database.
We just assume you
have a standard API,
maybe a sequel API and
I want to develop a solution
that does not have any prior
knowledge about your histogram.
I can do this kind of
user experience and
let me show you
the example here.
So, what do we do if I
show you the solution.
What we do is very simple.
It's one more
assumption we make.
We assume in your data or table
to be more specific you can pick
one attribute using which you
can slash your [INAUDIBLE] rate.
This is the assumption we make.
So in this example we assume,
we pick the time of
the tweet as a dimension.
As they mentioned in
the meetings this morning,
I have Twitter for about two
years and if I do a query for
all the tweets it takes
a long time to finish.
Instead, I can first
give you the results for
one week, the second week,
the third week.
Hopefully, by dividing this big
query into these small queries,
we call them mini-queries, each
of the mini-queries is more and
more responsive.
At the same time, we want to
progressively keep it updated.
One very simple solution
is the following, and
that's that I do this week by
week, so this is a behavior.
In this implementation,
in our first implementation,
was just fixed interval slice,
like one week or one month.
I do one query to give me all
the results for January, and
then results of February,
results of March and
piece them together.
We see a lot of issues here,
first issue is skewness,
data is not evenly distributed.
So of course we assume there is
a kind of index structure on
this attribute.
By accessing that
index structure,
the mini-query is much faster.
But still even in this case,
since the distribution of that
dimension is not uniform,
you get this behavior.
Sometimes it can be really fast,
sometimes it
can be very slow,
especially in the hurricane
example you can see last summer,
there's a peak.
Once you go to that range,
then the engine is very
busy processing that query,
the user waited for a long time.
This is one drawback,
the other drawback is even for
the database itself, even if
the distribution is uniform,
still your database is busy
with many other queries.
Even in a multi-tenant
environment,
your virtual machine
probably is serving lots of
different tenants.
So even the behavior
of the database can be
very unpredictable.
>> So I think I'm missing
the basic idea of slicing.
So from a user's point of view,
let's say I have an average
query, average aggregate.
So underneath,
you're doing some slicing that
I don't know about right?
>> Yes.
>> So you're giving me an answer
for, let's say, some slice and
that has a certain average.
Now once you add
the second slice,
that average may go up or
down, change drastically.
So as a user, what do I see?
>> You see this.
So what we are essentially
doing is giving the results
progressively.
>> No but I'm saying that okay,
if we look at something like
online aggregation, there was
some case a confidence interval,
here we don't have that.
>> This one, to some degree, you
can say, this is also one way to
do sampling, I'm doing
the sampling very consistently.
And I don't have any
assumption about execution,
that's why I cannot give
you any confidence.
If you do something like
a random sampling or
some of the work
the team here is doing.
Or you look at what Johan's
team has done 20 years ago
on online aggregation,
some of the approaches have
the assumption that the database
engine supports random sampling.
And we don't have the luxury
here, we want to take
the approach where I just have
a database sitting there,
I don't know what's inside it,
and I don't want to modify
database, and can I
do something in the middleware
that can be very self adaptive?
So in the whole solution,
when we started the system,
the collaborator system,
it doesn't know anything about
database, except of course API.
And so the distribution of
that dimension, I don't know,
especially since the user
can type in any keyword.
I cannot build a histogram for
every keyword, or
even combinations of keywords.
Even the behavior of
the database engine can be
very unpredictable.
Suddenly, it becomes faster,
sometimes, it can be slower.
The middleware should be able
to adjust itself to give you
the very smooth experience,
this is the approach we take.
And of course, which one is
right depends on the scenario.
If you have the access
to a source code,
you have the luxury to modify
your source code to provide this
random sampling interface, you
should go with that approach.
But the approach we take assumes
it just has a black box.
>> So it is only an assumption
here data are partitioned by
time, and so you can query
a specific time switch?
>> Right, yes,
you have one attribute,
using which you can
do core slicing.
>> That actually has to match
the grouping attribute?
>> Not necessarily.
>> So any attribute works?
>> But
you can go deeper to see that.
I think you can come up with
some requirements on the slicing
attribute, but in this query,
it's grouped by state.
What we're doing is,
first we get all the results for
January, and then do the count.
One requirement of the results
are aggregate-able, sum-able,
or you can keep some small
result and put them together.
But at a high level,
the requirement for
the slicing attribute
should be very minimal.
>> So like you said, you're
taking data week by week right?
>> Right.
>> So I'm just asking if
whether it's configurable that
you were taking it week by week,
or state by state,
because it could also do
it state by state, right?
>> Yeah, so we try to make
the middleware configurable
by allowing you to say, I do it
week by week or month by month.
But I want to mention that you
could take that approach, but
that experience is
not very pleasant.
Exactly I showed here, if you
just do it on a fixed interval,
due to the behavior of
the distribution and the data
engine, the times of delivered
results are not very smooth.
We want to give the user
a very smooth, or
what you call
a rhythmic approach,
that's exactly the solution
we came up with.
We just finished a paper
just maybe two weeks ago.
So the idea is the following,
at high level how can
middleware decide
a slicing interval for
the backend to make sure
the execution time of the meta
query can be finished
in a fixed time?
Two seconds, suppose when you're
developing a system you wanna
say, the middleware should give
the front end an update every
two seconds,
suppose this is a configuration.
In more of a dancing rhythm
here, how can you make sure
every two seconds you give
the front end an update?
Instead of delivering different
results at different times.
The key challenge is,
how can the middleware
model the behavior of
the distribution and
also model the behavior of
the engine at the black box and
then be adaptive by itself?
>> Maybe I'm missing something.
There is of course a time
constraint of [INAUDIBLE]
seconds, thus if you view that
as a constraint, I get that.
Is there an optimizing function?
>> In this formation,
we don't assume you have to
finish by a certain deadline.
We don't have the assumption.
>> You have the assumption?
>> No,
you don't have the assumption,
we just want to get the results
whatever time it takes,
we have to get the results.
We don't have this
deadline notion here.
>> Okay.
>> The focus of
this work is more
about the rhythm.
How can I give you
the results using this fixed,
two second windows?
>> But what is the trade off?
I mean, can you make
them every hour, right?
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> The slice can be very small.
>> We assume this two second,
this parameter,
is given by the system admin.
So in the NSC anatomy when you
develop a system you say I want
to give the user an update
every two seconds.
Two seconds in
parameter you can do,
it can be two seconds
it can be one second,
it could be five seconds and-
>> That's the updating not
slice time right?
>> Exactly so
that the middle has picked
out at the slicing time.
This exactly you
show where to solve.
So the system tells the system,
give the user update
every two seconds.
>> So
the question I was getting at,
okay, you have to
paint the slice.
Okay, I got it, and
we'll talk about that.
But either here it is,
this is over-constrained,
or it is a situation that
multiple solutions are involved,
I can sort of slice
in some 15 ways.
Then is there desirable
properties of this?
Are there optimizing
function for
this that you're
trying to get right?
There are the other
user I'm looking at.
Let's say you fix doing
non deterministic
one cannot get a certain
behavior and another time.
And, given that there is no
statistical Basis for it,
I don't know how do
you interpret it.
>> That's the purpose
of this slide okay?
So using a very simple
example let's say
we consider three different
ways to deliver results okay?
The first way I just ask for the
whole range and these are called
a schedule, and this schedule
takes Six second to finish.
But during six seconds,
user has to wait.
Okay?
A second schedule, magically,
you can give the user update
every two seconds, and
all of these four queries
run in the same time.
Of course,
altogether it takes longer time,
eight seconds, but the update
is very regular, very rhythmic.
The third approach also
issues four queries.
And the first query
took one second,
the second query
took three seconds,
the third took one second,
the fourth took three seconds.
So these four different queries,
they finished at
different times.
Well if whenever you get
a result you give the result
back to user.
Well this one the user sees the
result after one second and then
the user will wait for some time
after two seconds no update.
The user has to wait for one
more second to get the results.
The third one the user gets
the results immediately after
one second.
And the fourth one users
still needs to wait for
the one second after
the two second deadline.
So back to your question sardent
so I have three different
ways to get results how can
I quantify the quality here?
So we need to come with the
notion to say, which is better.
Okay?
And now when you come up with
the there is no single answer
here but I give you our
answer to the question.
We considered two things
in this formulation.
One total running time.
Ideally we want to make it
as small as possible, right?
Because overall we don't want
use the for a long time.
The second thing
we care about is.
If there's a pause,
and I say two seconds.
That means every time
the user gets an update you
want the user,
you do not want the user to wait
for longer than two seconds.
If the next query comes in
after the two second deadline
The longer the user waits,
the more penalty he had to pay.
So, what we formulate a problem.
The second issue is,
we would call it smoothness of
the result delivery, which is.
Suppose this is your previous
mini query that ends here,
to maintain this pace, we can
still wait for sometime for
the mini ware to
get the results.
And suppose this
is a in a window.
The next if the first
one was finished.
If this one took longer than
expected if it finishes here.
Then during this period
the user has to wait.
So the second factor we have
to consider in this whole
quality metric is how much
delay the user has to wait.
Ideally we want to minimize
the total running time.
We also want to minimize
the total number of waiting
time for the user.
So the solution we
come up with or
the answer we have is a
combination of the two factors.
A total running time which is
the, we call the Cost T And
the total delay, and we use,
a factor, a constant
to decide how much a penalty
we want to give to a delay.
Of course,
we can talk about what,
it's this one is really
a golden standard,
but the idea is fair, the
combination of those factors.
>> But if fewer comms are ready,
and you use very small slides,
say one millisecond,
>> Yes.
>> Then DILV is basically zero?
>> Yes, this will be very low.
>> I see so
the cost will be higher.
>> Because you are sending a lot
of queries in the background.
>> And
how do you model that cost?
>> For now for our proof
it's just a matter of time.
Again we don't know
how many CPU cycle,
the resources are available
in the database system.
We don't have the access.
So that either way,
it's just a matter of time.
Of course, if you have
the access to the database
resources, you can come up with
a better way to model the cost.
>> So just a clarification
again, are these many queries,
are they being executed in
parallel, some of them are, or?
>> It's the previous question.
>> So far,
in the current implementation,
we assume they
are done sequentially.
We did my experiment where
the meteor could send them out
at the same time.
Our finding is you're kind of
overdoing your work, right.
You're competing with
resources with other people.
So you could do it, but for
our solution we assume
to do it sequentially.
Okay.
>> So the metric that you
are saying is running time or
is it like?
>> This one?
>> Yeah.
>> It's total running time.
>> But when you're trying to
optimize, figure this out,
in the quote unquote in
your planning phase,
you don't have access to that.
>> Right we don't have it.
So this is more like a ruler
to measure your quality and
at the beginning we
tried to formulate
kind of an optimization problem.
We found it's really hard.
Because it's an online problem,
everything will change as
you move on to schedule.
So what we do is we
take a greedy approach
meaning every time when we
generate the next media query,
based on this function I
try to be very greedy.
I don't claim any optimality.
At the end I want to
generate a schedule,
I use this function to measure
the quality of my schedule.
So I don't go with this.
I'm just greedy.
Okay, so So this is a framework
of what we're doing,
we call it Drum which stands for
Delivery, dont Drum,
Results Upon Met Milestones.
Okay so one of the reasons you
use a drum is either the pace,
you have to Meet
the requirement.
So the idea,
I mean you have seen this
structure in many other places.
The whole framework is very
adaptive, meaning you have
a query and the middleware will
initially generate some very
conservative mini-queries by
using very small intervals.
Okay, you must first
get some results, and
then you send the mini-query
To the backend and
then the backend
keeps the result.
The also keeps track of
the numbers, performance.
And that information will
be fed into this module
to model the behavior being
that information will be use
by the generator to mini-query.
So that's why to you
This adapts the width of
the slices that you're doing
to generate the mini-queries.
>> Correct.
>> Do you also do any adaptation
about choosing a different
dimension along which to do the
>> We don't do it.
The reason is from the user
experience perspective,
the UI is fixed.
It's always time.
>> Because if you try
the to the space,
the UI doesn't So
this is the idea, okay?
So, now talk about details
We want to model the
relationship between the slice
in time and run time.
So the one thing we do have
is a regression model.
So [INAUDIBLE] regression, but
you can [INAUDIBLE] any
other regression model.
Any regression model
can not be perfect.
We also have model to model
the behaviour of the errors
and I think maybe I will
spend almost like 40 minutes.
I think you get the main idea
of what we're doing here.
So, if you don't mind, okay,
just wrap up with this one,
move on to the next one here.
But you get the idea,
we tried to
use as middleware to do your
response or queries, without
making a very strong assumption
about the back-end database.
Here is what you do, yeah.
>> Just one question.
>> Sure.
>> Studies show that pray for
this constant query
response time?
>> We don't,
we were talking to HCFI coder,
to see who can do either study
>> I think this is expertise.
We haven't done it yet.
But from my bias perception,
we see,
the 16th of width
doesn't look good.
>> So this is considering
the time, right,
so I was thinking always
the time might not be the thing.
It might be that [INAUDIBLE]
only for one second.
However, the amount of data that
comes through that one second
be a lot, so shouldn't
you consider this slicing
as some estimation of how many
data will come on that slice and
then time them together.
>> Exactly.
When we decide the slides
in individual width,
we do consider the factor.
How do you make that amount
of data conversation.
>> That's the answer is a
combination of the equation and
the air model.
We try to intuitively if
I wanna finish a query
within two seconds by
using the mini model,
maybe I should have used
maybe it seven days.
But a user [INAUDIBLE] window
have a risk of missing deadline.
So actually be a little bit
conservative maybe by using
five days or four days.
So that is already captured
by the error model there.
So I'm not targeting just to
finish the whole thing in
two seconds.
That's too risky.
I need to be a little
bit conservative.
But that's
>> So given discussion,
it seems from a user study of
this experience seems kind of
crucial [LAUGH]
>> Yeah,
that's a real
question right there.
>> So, how
>> Is so
much tied to the CANR
>> Yes, yes, yes.
>> And not so much,
>> [LAUGH] [INAUDIBLE]
>> Sir, you are being recorded.
>> Okay yeah, so
just answer my question.
>> I think this is not the first
time people suggest that we use
the studies.
I think we should do it,
we should do it.
>> Okay.
>> And record it.
So I want to use the remaining
time to talk about
a second system.
>> So of all this beside,
this is enough slicing,
how much to slice or not.
In this case,
as far as I could understand,
wouldn't a simple
histogram help you here?
>> I don't have a histogram
>> And
was it particular to because
in relation to [CROSSTALK]
>> To discuss this morning.
If the username keywords I
can build the histogram for
some keyword I
don't know I don't.
I start from scratch.
Are different All right.
So I want to take the meantime
to talk about second system,
which is to me also
very exciting.
I did a lot of work
in text processing.
I did a startup about
text processing,
and I feel text is
a very rich domain.
There are a lot
of opportunities.
This new system I am building
is called the In the earlier,
later we'll name
it because system.
At a high level, it is
a system that come supports
text processing Okay and
I'm going to show you
the reason is everybody in
this room can write code.
Some people without
IT background
they cannot write a code.
But how can we
make it easier for
these people, including us,
to do some text processing very
easily without writing
a single line of code right?
If I can finish one thing
Within five minutes,
I don't wanna do it in one hour.
It's about the cost, okay?
So what we're building is
a web service context error.
Using which a system
can easily drag and
drop some basic operators
to formulate a work flow. Okay?
I didn't need any any software.
Texera is a business web.
So here I'm also using
Twitter as an example.
And so, I can just look at scan.
Refresh your page.
So I want to allow a person
to analyze tweets,
without writing
a single line of code.
So I can say I do a scan.
I have a lot of tables there.
I pick one table called
the data for last week.
I can just see the results.
We know this is
[INAUDIBLE] with a limit.
Top readers.
I run a query, and
I should be able to see some of
them within ten seconds to it.
That's not innovative.
Let's do more analysis.
Suppose I only wanted to look
at all the Tweets mentioning
a particular keyword,
say, hurricane.
I go here.
I do a keyword search.
I need to specify
the attribute and
a keyword I used,
like a hurricane, hurricane and
I gave the name of
the results like a operator.
Search results, so
it link us to operators, and
these two operators.
So this is a new query, so
you can click each of them,
you see this one should
have hurricane here.
So, other analysis.
Suppose I want to
do recognition.
Okay so what I can do is I
go to this manual option.
I pick recognition and
I pick one of the attributes and
I want to locate pick one
of the types noun, verb.
Suppose I want to look
at locations okay and
I say location results. Okay.
>> Sir,
are you looking for
all the results.
Or, like, I want to see,
is there a notion of ranking,
is there a notion of top ten,
or, because-
>> We have limit.
You know what databases people
are no good at a ranking.
[LAUGH] We give you time
[INAUDIBLE] [LAUGH].
That's the difference
between our database.
You know it.
>> So with entity [INAUDIBLE]
>> In my experience,
that is an operator that is
incredibly sensitive to context,
and whether I wanna
recognize products
historical figures
of this stuff.
How can you have a general
purpose single entity
recognition upgrade?
>> This standard
entity recognizer is
wrapping Stanford NLP.
We wrap Lucene.
We wrap Stanford NLP. We wrap
Energy K will route disguise.
>> But when you do it's still,
what your positioning this as
a one stop shop for all sorts
of domains in task right.
>> Yes.
>> So in a way
whatever you route
>> Still has to
generalize and-
>> Correct.
>> In your experience
is that the case or
is there some way to customize
the HTTP recognition [CROSSTALK]
>> It's both,
if you look at machine right,
Very powerful search engine,
stemming, ranking, free search,
multi language support,
they're all available.
We just wrap it and
bring it back to you.
And some of the operators
that you use on your machine,
standardized the rapid.
At the same time, if the user
wants to add their own logic,
we should allow
the user to do it.
>> So wait, so
there's one interpretation of
this which is a query builder.
All I'm doing is I have
individual components and
I'm just,
not necessarily by planning, but
a workflow, kind of, right.
And it's just that,
it's a visual thing and
the boxes are what they are.
What is the semantics
of this workflow, for
each one figure out what it is
and whatever the semantics is,
I take the results and put it in
this pipe and that's it, right.
Is this how I should view it or
this is something else?
>> It's for text.
>> What?
>> It's invented for text.
>> That's okay but.
>> Do we have a solution
on the market?
I don't see it.
>> I didn't say I misunderstand
everything [CROSSTALK]
>> When you work on
the [INAUDIBLE] that's fine,
but I don't see any
solution on market.
There are solutions that
are standalone software packages
like 9 [INAUDIBLE] AutoRx,
these are a few solutions,
either open source or
proprietary.
They are not web based,
they're not cloud based.
And from a user perspective,
they do not want to
install software.
>> Do you have any
debugging support for this?
>> We will.
>> To ask the question in
a different way lets say
I firmly believe in Vivex Entity
Extractor as far superior.
>> [LAUGH]
>> He's very good at this.
>> What would it take for
me to actually integrate one
specific entity recognizer in
your software, is that possible?
>> Yeah it is possible, we first
of all it took us about one and
a half years to reach
this milestone.
Saying and doing are different,
it took a lot of time
to reach this step.
A few things that we are doing,
I want to summarize the few
things we are going to do.
One accessibility, you have your
own logic or even some package
you want to wrap, we want to
make the process very easy.
Want to support Python,
we want to support Java and R,
these are common languages.
How can we allow the developer
to wrap their own logic into
this whole pipeline?
That's one, we had to do it.
Second is debugability, and
while you have this long-running
job on a very large amount of
records, the whole execution
can take a long time.
How can you give a user some
kind of a progress report
of where you are in
the whole execution?
Allow the user to even pause
one of the operators and
do some evaluation
of the state of that
operator to see those
immediate results,
even do some latency to see
where that record comes from.
We now allow the user
to debug it.
>> It's more than
just debugging right?
If I know like principally let's
say sort of all names that have
a middle name that's a single
initial are misrecognized.
How do I actually then,
then enable that feedback right?
It's one thing to recognize
that, it's another thing to
actually systematically modify
my entity recognition component.
>> So far, we don't have
the feedback mechanism,
we don't have it yet.
We talked about the [INAUDIBLE].
This kind of software
are very powerful in terms of
allowing the users to highlight
some of the places, and
then they can recommend
some rules here.
We are not there yet,
but down the road.
Let him talk about
a kernel focus,
accessibility, debugability and
usability.
And one more thing we
care about really about
potential securability.
And so far the whole thing
runs on a single engine, and
nothing can prevent us from
running one operator in
a parallel environment.
Because we know text processing
can be very expensive,
can take hours or
days to finish.
So, if we can parallelize
the execution of each operators
to this cluster then
that's even more powerful.
This utilities have
not been done yet,
which is only
the initial prototype.
And the good news is for
both systems I'm presenting
here, they are used by people.
In my talk abstract
we are working with
some UCI researchers,
they're not from ICS.
They are working public health
politics to use social
media to do their analysis.
And they love the first
timer because you
can easily see the data.
And you also use this one here
because they do not want to
write a program, they do not
want to install software,
they do not want
to apply patches.
And this is a big advantage
of cloud based trend,
everybody here knows how
important the trend in cloud is.
And we believe even if you take
the idea of either
[INAUDIBLE] or [INAUDIBLE],
push it to the cloud, and
make it very easy to use.
And make the execution detached
from the front end, and
the user can access
the execution from anywhere.
Even allow multiple users to
share that execution interface,
this is very powerful.
That's why Google Docs is very,
very, very easy to
use because multiple people
can share the same document.
This infrastructure can allow
multiple developers to share
the same workflow without using
the remote desktop, right.
So this is, I believe this is
a trend, and a lot of the new
challenges we had to solve in
this new architecture here.
It was certainly imbued in this.
You give me an idea a round
the field the machine, NRTK,
standard NRP, maybe a Vivex
future model we can wrap it.
And then we wanna
make it extensible by
allowing the user to write
out their own logic.
So those things are already
happening here,
so where was the technical part?
The technical part, you already
got a second technical part,
let me maybe give
you one slide here.
And one interesting
thing is how to,
some people ask the question,
how is it different
from a database engine?
At the high level its all
about operators forming a tag,
at that level they are the same.
But the main difference is
inside a database system,
people don't interact
with operators.
People interact with the system
using SQL, using string, but
here you, the user, can interact
with each operator, okay.
So the architecture
is very different.
A second difference is,
inside a database system,
how many operators we have,
maybe 30, 40 at the most.
But in this text
domain there is so
many different
operations you can do.
The number of operators
is much much larger.
I heard they claim to have
more than 1,000 operators for
different purposes.
Because we have this whole
architecture that allows
a new user, developer,
to contribute a new operator
to the whole framework.
Because the whole thing is
very open, very extensible.
Now, when you develop
such a engine,
how can we make it easy for
a new operator to implement it?
That's very different
from a database case,
where everything is
under control, but
here it's more open-ended.
So what do we do,
in our current engine,
is every operator has kind of
a descriptor in a JSON format.
The descriptor has all the
information about this operator
in addition to the code,
of course you have to
have the code logic.
The descriptor could have how
many inputs what is the output.
Even the front end, what kind
of icon you want to use, and
what kind of description do you
want to attach to this operator.
And from a developer perspective
as long as you use a framework
to describe a new operator
with the code and
the meta data The whole thing
will be integrated through
the whole system very easily.
>> So you're printing an
arbitrary offering of somebody
else's code.
There may not be the same
realization of multiplayer.
So who has to write that?
>> So first of all, we have not
done that UDF part yet, right?
Because I'm not saying every
package can be wrappable, right?
The model might
not be wrappable.
But there's certain protocols
the person has to follow,
like what's the input
with the output?
Right, so, but I want to
identify the commonality and
make it easier for the developer
to write a piece of code.
But so far, the way we
integrated NRTK which is in
Python is pretty interesting
because we tried different ways
to include Python
in our Java engine.
One approach is to
use a Java class to
interpret all
the different Python code.
The other one is running
a Python at a separate process.
And and Python process
use IPC to [INAUDIBLE].
We take the second approach.
But even for second approach,
there's one question
which is how the DVM and
the Python process share
information back and forth.
How you can minimize
overhead by doing batching?
Those things need
to be figured out.
>> It seems to me that
[INAUDIBLE] something like
SQL Server intergration services
which has a very similar sort of
work in the sense that there are
a bunch of built-in operators
which you as a user can
connect for your tasks.
And they also have custom
script operators that you can
write your own scripts and
put it into the thing and
as long as it meets certain
input/output criteria,
you can plug it in
anywhere into the Python.
In a sense, those kinds of
engines have been built, right?
So what do you see as the new
challenges because it's text
processing?
>> I'm not saying this idea
of formulating a workflow
using drag and
droppable operators is new.
Microsoft did it.
[INAUDIBLE] did it.
I believe that the uniqueness
here is the cloud.
I believe if you pick some idea,
you can make a similar argument
why does Microsoft move
from Office to Office 3.06?
You have to move everything
to the cloud, and
that is architecture shift.
Previously, you run the whole
thing on your single desktop.
I don't know the software image.
I saw some GUI to
formulate a query.
I saw that interface.
I don't know what's that
one you're talking about.
But in general I believe the
software you're talking about
is something is running
on your local machine.
>> Is this for the ETL scenario
primary targeted to that?
>> Right, but
I don't know whether it's
a based I don't know yet. But-
>> But
we can think about that
>> Yeah.
>> I guess the question
is basically,
because it's cloud
based [INAUDIBLE]?
>> I feel few-
>> As a functionality, we
are fine with the examples you
gave of Office 365 and whatnot.
Makes sense, right,
nobody is questioning that.
But from a technical
perspective, what's changed?
[INAUDIBLE]
>> I don't have a perfect
answer to your question
because we are also exploring.
I really do the [INAUDIBLE]
on gut feeling here.
I see people want this.
This is my show dance or
non-technical answer.
If I go deeper, I believe
first when to the cloud,
there is a very big potential
of automatically scale up
the whole competition, right?
If you have a job that's
very expensive to run,
then in the cloud, you have
a much better freedom to launch
multiple virtual machines to
paralyze some of the operators.
The web gives you
the opportunity.
I know they look similar but
that's not what
there talking about.
>> The position logic.
>> Yes, that one is a new
opportunity you cannot explore
on a single desktop.
In addition,
in terms of the user experience,
I think is very different.
Of course, you may not say
the technical but when designing
architecture since we're using
this conservative architecture,
the execution of your
logic should be detached
from your fountain.
You can easily set up and
open a new browser and
attach that one here.
Engineer or technical,
we don't know.
But you have to think about this
whole thing very differently.
You can say the idea has been
implemented by RapidaMiner.
RapidaMiner is using everything
as a travel program of
running on a single machine but
I believe software's like
RapidaMiner have spent a
significant amount of effort on
even the UIDs that's on there.
That's why it's very hard for
them to migrate
to the web cloud.
They can't.
They have a burden they
have to carry with them.
Because us,
we start from scratch.
From day one,
we do the web interface.
Maybe one or
two years down the road,
I have a more technical
answer to your question.
>> You're going to have
to beat Unix pipes.
It's very interesting to
listen to the questions.
Everybody here's
a database person.
[LAUGH]
>> You are also a database
person.
>> The thing that would
this kind of thing.
And Unix pipes were
actually used exactly for
this except it's not JSON.
It's a different data model.
It's comma or
space separated fields carriage
return separated fields.
>> I would say that hoc
is probably [INAUDIBLE].
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah, but-
>> And you talk about the cloud
in terms of scale out but
probably the first thing that
people that would worry about
is how to get parallelism on
a multi core machine that
shared memory because they just
thought they're a lot of
performance issues there.
We know just for
database processing,
query processing to get
the most out of the machine.
I have a hard time thinking
about text processing that is of
such a scale that you would go
to multiple machines to get
there.
>> I have one billion
ways to do everything And
the user did not want to
wait for a long time.
So having the ability to
run the whole thing on 100
machines will help for sure.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> But back to your question,
I agree with you that even on a
single machine there is a lot of
potential to paralyze
the competition using multiple
cores, but, strategically,
back to [INAUDIBLE] question.
I will not focus on that one yet
because that issue also exists
on a single desktop software.
>> So if I understand you right,
what you're really talking
about is, I'm trying to see in
terms of machine
architecture in the Cloud.
How does it look, like,
we are busy moving your boxes.
I can sort of, think of them as
a bit of like, Micro-services.
I can say, hey, they have their
own class, so they have their
own logic, they run in their
own, in their own VMs.
>> Right.
>> And your stuff runs and
then if you [INAUDIBLE] service
[INAUDIBLE] they send it back.
And you connect to all
these micro services.
If you really want to be kind
of cloud native, you should
think in terms of micro
services in that case, right?
But then there are all
kinds of issues, right?
In that case, your storage
[INAUDIBLE] Rest API through
which you're communicating and
that's pretty much it.
So it's some with
the matter of fewer, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And it managing and
what side of the network.
They may not be
on the same rack.
You can't make any assumption
on where those machines are.
So to get there,
the question is to get the right
performance architecturally.
What are you assuming?
So as you said,
that the model is not new.
We are going to cloud.
But with that comes a question,
what is running where?
What did they share?
Where is the network?
How much is being transferred
across the network, and
what are the options?
>> Very good point.
There are a lot of questions
about architecture.
We could run each
of the operators as
a microservice using
some standard REST API.
Currently, we're looking at
the architecture where we use,
I think they're called
actor model [INAUDIBLE]
>> She just talked to Phil.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE] I'm next on
the agenda.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think that's a coincidence?
>> So
he gets another
half an hour extra.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, hopefully by the end of
this quarter,
by the end of this year
>> We're going to switch
the whole thing to
the action model.
Because the idea is each
of Twitter is running as
a thread with separate queue.
All of the different Twitters
communicate with each other by
sending messages to the queue.
A big advantage of this
architecture is I can pause it.
Because each of the actors
is running using a thread,
like a part of thread.
Currently I'm using a single
thread the pull model.
So we plan to assist the push
model with all the actors money.
So I have a got a feeling,
I dont have any ground
crews to support it which is
Microsoft might be to expensive.
>> Okay.
>> That's being fair.
>> That's my feeling.
I think, I think.
>> I'm not reprimanding
Microsoft.
I'm just asking you in this
spectrum, where you sit.
>> I guess the model should be
more efficient, because it is
the same framework using the
interthread and communication.
That one should be
cheaper than HP computer.
That's my kind of thing.
We can go to the action model.
In fact,
the cloud map we saw earlier,
you see videos in the actual
model, but we're using Ascata.
In this one, we're using Java.
All right so
I reached the end of my talk but
I wanna say one more thing
which is in this text domain
mission learning models
are used very common.
And one common question people
ask is in the whole pipeline for
data analysis machine learning
is very important that
where does machine learning
into this whole architecture.
So the way I see it is we
have this backend Asterix to
be running at a database
system to do ingestion.
And we use the to do
the visualization.
And then we use the text
the older one we call it TextDB.
That does a based formulation.
And this whole suite of
solutions can be used
to help you to do
preparation for machinery.
You can use it to store data,
visualize data and
then analyze data and
once you use whole suite
to prepare some
data or label the data, then
you can train the model here.
You get what I mean here.
So you use the whole
thing to train the model.
The model is more like
a mix ii just a file, and
then this model can be
integrated back to either to
textera as no of the operators.
Once we finish
the [FOREIGN] feature.
Or, data is being ingested
into the database.
This model can be used as a kind
of UDF to do some offline
processing, or even run time
while you do the visualization.
For those trees you can even use
UDF to do the online labeling.
So the short message is
the whole suite of solutions and
machine learning are kind
of complimentary,
we are focusing on
the data preparation site.
Okay conclusion here and
this is acknowledgements and
thank you especially for
all the support.
[APPLAUSE]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Excuse me I have one question
about the cloud various
like think of that.
So you mentioned that you
don't have random access to
database and that's the reason
you don't get samples on a daily
basis to answer the quirks.
However you have this database
there that you have data there
and you have access to
the eskimo database to translate
the query to the SQL query,
is that correct?
>> Correct, the middleware
has the access to the data.
>> What I don't understand is
that in realistic you are the
tutor or a third party, and when
you are a third party you get
these data in store, and now
you have access to these data.
So where are you
exactly computing it?
>> On some machines, the backend
database has a large amount of
data, and the middleware
knows the API, the schema,
but the middleware is more like
an accelerator to some degree.
It's more like a data
warehousing accelerator
that sits on top
of the database.
Database and here.
So, previously the application
layer talks to the database
directly to ask queries but
those queries can be slow.
By putting Cloudberry in
between which also knows
the database schema this layer
can use all techniques to make
those queries at the application
layer much faster.
This is the position.
>> It does also,
they do the same right,
the [INAUDIBLE] the Twitter.
But they also do the crawling,
they have the data, and
also they do the [INAUDIBLE]
of those questions.
>> Yeah Cloudvarius is
a general purpose software,
it's not just for Twitter.
The database can be anything, so
it's not specific to Twitter.
>> Okay thanks a lot for
a very interesting [INAUDIBLE]
>> [APPLAUSE]